[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored and
exclusive one-on-one interview with the
Prime Minister of Australia Anthony
albanesi a man who's flown right across
the world to be here in London for the
correlation of King Charles III which
might strike you as a little odd given
he's a die-hard republican who wants to
get rid of the head of state in his
country being a member of our royal
family he also wants to get rid of the
monarchy
I sit down with Alvin easy for a long
wide-ranging interview and we talk about
the Royals about the monarchy about
whether he'll take an oath of allegiance
to the king
at the service on Saturday we also talk
about other big pressing World issues
China Taiwan America is Biden too old to
be president should Trump be allowed to
run again now he's been indicted we've
taught canceled culture wokeries day
medva everage it's an extraordinary
interview that ends in a remarkable way
with some of the most personal
Revelations I think I've ever got from
any world leader to tell the full
amazing story of this man's Journey 2
ends in a remarkable way with the Prime
Minister revealing extraordinary
personal details about his journey to
become the most powerful man in
Australia it's a story of his mother the
father he thought was dead a reunion in
Italy and a very touching deathbed scene
this is an interview with a world leader
like few others
Anthony Albanese one on one
[Music]
the Prime Minister welcome to Britain
good to be with you and glad to be in
London I have a strict rule I have to
confess normally I don't fraternize with
any Australians in the run-up to an
ashes series but I have made an
exception for you well it's going to be
a cracker of a series and uh hopefully
we'll go well any prediction
I always think we're going to win even
when we're rubbish I thought we're going
to win you've got to you've got to back
your team a legendary Australian
cricketer Keith Miller who flew with
your Air Force in World War II
it's once asked about pressure and he
said pressure is having a measurement up
your bleep
you've been prime minister not even a
year yet
how's it going I mean just the reality
when I last saw you you were contesting
the vanilla election
and you've been a career politician but
this moment now this period what's it
been like for you I'm enjoying it it's
an incredible privilege and an honor to
be the prime minister of a country that
I love dearly and one that I think is
the greatest country on Earth with
respect to the UK but I think can be
even greater in the future you're here
for our coronation of King Charles III
how do you feel about that you're a
lifelong Republican
what are you doing here prime minister
well I think you can be a lifelong
Republican which I am and still respect
our institutions and certainly I have a
great deal of respect for King Charles I
am having an audience with him this
afternoon and I'm very much looking me
in the morning the king in the afternoon
I like the way your schedule's going
brother I'm very much out looking
forward to it uh I had a terrific
meeting with him at the palace when I
was here for his mother's funeral that
was a real moment of of reflection that
was an extraordinary time and it's a
great honor to be here representing
Australia all Australians Wish King
Charles well regardless of the different
views that people will have about our
constitutional Arrangements
the queen you would hope for funerals
you said and you actually went to her
lying estate at Westminster Hall what
was that experience like for you it was
very moving the the queen uh Elizabeth
was of course the only uh Head of State
uh in my lifetime up to that point and
she was a constant in our lives a
reassuring presence so her passing was
something that was a very significant
event
but she also I think was very loved and
respected by all
to lead
your nation and the Commonwealth for
seven decades is extraordinary we won't
see that certainly you and I won't see
that again and I think people uh the the
cues as we we went running one morning
along the Thames and the cues of people
including Australians who had traveled
uh to London in order to queue for 36
hours to pay their respects to the the
Her Majesty lying in State uh was a
remarkable time when you were standing
there with your partner and you were
paying your own personal respects did
you feel emotional in that moment
notwithstanding your your long-held
position about the monarchy well it's a
moment in history I had the great honor
of I met at Queen Elizabeth at the at
the palace during the first G20 that was
held during the global financial crisis
and her leadership and her capacity her
strength was quite remarkable and her
passing was a very significant moment in
the world's history and unlike even
previous monarchs of course she
came to that position at such a young
age and during the era the first era of
Television modern Communications so the
pressure that she was under during those
seven decades of course grew and she
carried herself with such dignity and
Grace during that entire period
your birth was actually delayed because
of the queen well true right my mother
was well kind of true my mother was on
her way to the hospital in 1963 and the
queen was of course visiting
Australia and my mother insisted on
going through the streets and seeing the
banners and the commemorations for her
visit on the way to give birth to me so
that that was my mum and that was that
is something uh that is an example my
mother voted
yes in the Republic but she had enormous
respect for her majesty of the queen
this question of what happens to
Australia whether it becomes a republic
it's obviously it's not going to go away
many people think it's inevitable Hugh
Jackman was recently quoted one of your
great national heroes saying it's
inevitable you voted in the 1999
referendum in favor of Republic and said
it's inevitable everybody accepts that
but that referendum came back 55 against
uh saying yes to a republic
my first question are you going to have
another referendum while you're prime
minister
my uh sole priority that I've put
forward uh for constitutional change is
to recognize Aboriginal Torres Strait
Islander people in our Constitution and
to listen to them through a voice what's
called a voice essentially that they be
consulted on matters that affect them
and that's a referendum that will hold
between October and December that's my
timetable I'm not looking beyond that I
think that Australia should have for an
Australian as our head of state I don't
shy away from that I haven't changed my
views but my priority is constitutional
recognition I can't imagine going
forward for example as was suggested has
been suggested by some legitimately that
we should be having another referendum
on the Republic
before that occurs for me uh the the
absolute priority is once you've done
that recognition right but once you've
done that it would be odd for somebody
who's such a die-hard republican as you
notwithstanding your respect for the key
players in the royal family and the
monarchy which you've shown in this
interview already notwithstanding that'd
be very odd wouldn't it if you were a
prime minister and you didn't want
another referendum movie otherwise
what's been the point of posing it all
this time well look I I think at some
stage in the future
that will occur would you like it to
happen but either your tenure what I
don't want to do is to be a prime
minister who presides over just
constitutional debates
and that's right and that's why they are
they are but so is dealing with the
challenge of climate change getting an
economy that works for people making
more things in Australia engaging in our
region uh to restore our relationships
as one of the tasks that that I've had
as prime minister so I've said quite
clearly that that's my priority uh
you'll you'll know because there'll be a
feeling from the bottom up as well a a
demand for
another another vote isn't something
that can be imposed from the top because
it won't be successful when that that
demand is there I'm sure a vote will be
held how close to that feeling do you
think Australia is because the polls
have been all over the place I I don't
see it as being imminent
but if you were to win a second term
potentially you could have a referendum
well I don't see as being imminent
you're being very diplomatic here prime
minister is that because you're here for
a monarchy which many of your supporters
would be like hang on you've come here
to London to watch a king being crowned
the head of an institution that you just
don't agree with yeah but part of part
of the job of being the Australian prime
minister is to represent all Australians
not just to put forward my own views
which are clearly there but it is
important that the Australian prime
minister and the governor general and
all of the governors and we have some
prominent Australians coming along as
well on Saturday Sam Kerr yeah great
footballer she will be the flag bearer
on on Saturday and and I chose her put
her forward I thought that was a really
appropriate thing to do someone who's a
a young Dynamic Australian sportswoman
who hopefully will lead us to World Cup
Glory uh in the Women's World Cup that's
uh that's coming up being hosted in
Australia in a couple of months time so
what are you going to do in Westminster
Abbey when you are urged to say the oath
of Allegiance I did to King Charles I I
do that every term well I know are you
going to say it in the Abbey with the
world's cameras watching I I I will do
what's entirely appropriate as the
representative of Australia which is
Australians made a choice in 1999 and
one of the things that you've got to do
is to accept Democratic outcomes we made
that choice and I will certainly engage
in that spirit so you will say that as I
have as I have done 10 times
yes but just to be clear in there it's
been confusionable whether you will as
the Prime Minister Australia in the
Abbey that's the fact that you will say
the oath as as the Prime Minister of
Australia it's expected that that I will
do that but that doesn't mean of course
that Australians don't have uh a wide
range of views and it's also the case
that as Australian prime minister I'm
accountable to the Australian people I
mean that that too I serve and I have
that great honor do you know the words
two the oath
well I know the oath that that I give in
the uh in in Parliament each time I
swear that I will pay true allegiance to
your majesty into your heirs and
successes according to law so help me
God there's been a lot of of actually I
would say a lot of Kickback here
about this entreaty which has come from
the Archbishop of Canterbury
the the public the British public and a
wider world of course including those in
the Commonwealth should all crowd run
their TV sets and recite this because as
people have pointed out
heirs and successes
well that could be if we're unlucky
prince Andrew
or God forbid
Harry and Megan
well people will make their own
decisions uh on on Saturday but I think
it will be a very significant historic
event
the Australian Republican movement the
Australian Republic movement has called
on all Australians to pledge allegiance
to Australians and Australian values on
Coronation Day and not quote obey the
Absurd request of King Charles for us to
pledge fealty to him and his heirs and
successes as a republican from Australia
what's your message to them I pledge
allegiance to the Australian people each
and every day
and that's our democratic system that we
have and it's one yeah I think people
will have uh these these views but I
think that but they're your views
absolutely I I pledge my allegiance to
the Australian people they are the
people I'm accountable for but are you
at all worried tomorrow that you're
Republican
people back in Australia the side that
you actually agree with they're going to
see you on Saturday
declaring your oath of allegiance to not
just King Charles but to all his heirs
and successors when actually really what
you want to do is get rid of the
molecule it is a strange conundrum right
no no no
our position that the position of the
Australian Republican movement isn't
about getting rid of the monarchy that's
the decision for the UK the decision of
the arm is that an Australian should be
the Australian head of state yeah and
that's what I agree with I think you
would do that but Australia would I
would hope continue to be involved in
the Commonwealth but I'm at The View
that an Australian should be our head of
state there's a new poll out today about
the British Public's view of this
overwhelming support for the monarchy
two-thirds said it may seem a strange
system in this day and age but it works
and that's kind of my view about this I
mean I feel uneasy about this over to be
honest I won't be saying it the way they
want me to because I'm not going to
commit to having allegiance to Prince
Harry
um
but there's an interesting statement
there by the public which is they know
it's a bit anachronistic we know it's
kind of weird to have people
in palaces not paying proper taxes and
all of course we do and yet the British
public feels quite strongly the
overriding benefits of a monarchy
outweigh the negatives and that's the
right of the British people to determine
uh that's that's the point I'm making
here
I guess as someone who supports an
Australian head of state we should
determine who our head of state is and
the United Kingdom should determine who
their head of state is you do have a
view about the the actual institution of
the monarchy well that that I I I'm not
a monarchist uh you would get rid of it
I I well we don't have an Australian
royal family that's that's the point but
you have one of our roles as your head
of state exactly but that's the point
because that's a contradiction in itself
that's why I think Australia should have
our own head of state and I'm at The
View
that I think that should be an appointed
head of state there shall be some uh
process whereby our democratically
elected institutions in the House of
Representatives and the Senate have a
say in that there's various models it's
one of the things that's held back the
change in Australia is uh the failure to
agree on a way forward but I would I
would hope that Australia would still of
course remain a member of the
Commonwealth of an Australia and an
undemocratic monarchy really exist going
forward go forward 10 20 30 years we've
seen the rapid removal of most
monarchies in Europe in the last 50
years or so I mean do you think that a
monarchy the idea the concept has any
real future well that's a matter for the
United Kingdom I myself am a Democrat
and believe in Democratic institutions
and that that is how we should be
governed and that is how we should
determine so you don't believe you don't
believe in the idea no I'm a republican
but that doesn't mean that I don't
respect the institution which is there
which plays a role in our system of
government I have to meet with the
governor general regularly the governor
general has to sign off on our pieces of
legislation and I respect that and I
think that it's important that
institutions which are there that have
been determined be given that respect
and I see my role as the Australian
prime minister in doing that when you
see the king later
um how are you going to explain that
you've decided to remove his image or
not have his image on your five dollar
banknotes given it's always
traditionally been whoever the Monarch
is
you've decided as a government you're
not going to do this are you going to
are you going to cough up to this when
you see King Charles I I I'm sure that
it won't be raised the Kings
portrait the official one will be on the
back of every coin and of course our
dollar notes uh the truth is that
they've all changed at various times as
well including the five dollar note so
this was I think Much Ado About Nothing
frankly uh well except you've always had
the Queens no it hasn't always been on
the five dollar note really that's
actually not true and indeed we we
haven't even have we've had different uh
currencies of course we went decimal in
in 1966 so there's a whole history of
church nothing personal there not at all
not at all the decision was made
actually by The Reserve Bank uh wasn't
even made by the government an
independent body they consulted the
government and uh we were were
comfortable with the decision that was
made to have an an indigenous
representation artwork on the five
dollar note which of course with the one
dollar note that was abolished that used
to have so the lowest denomination of
note of currency used to have the
indigenous artwork on it
Harry dominated
headlines for three years do you have a
view about them do you think they should
be able to keep their Royal titles ah I
I I have of all the things that come
across my desk that I'm concerned about
global inflation uh the increasingly
insecure world the war in Ukraine uh
dealing with the challenge of climate
change I've got to say Harry and Megan
have not been front and center of my
thoughts will you be seeking hurry out
in the Abbey for a little chat uh I
spoke to Harry very briefly at the at
his his mother's funeral uh his grandma
his grandmother sorry and passed on my
respects and
I I I don't know whether I'll see him or
not but if I did I'd say hello
Australia's other Queen Dame Edna
average very sadly died Barry Humphries
he created that amazing Comic character
um
what were your thoughts about Barry
Humphries Jessup Barry Humphries was the
quintessential Australian character
uh Barry Humphries brought Australians
Australian laricanism really to life and
in the characters uh including of course
most famously uh Dame Edna but Sandy
Stone and and of course let's make him
forget who can forget that great
Australian politician Les Patterson
Australians have a particular sense of
humor I think British humor is different
from American humor I'm I'm a fan of
Monty Python going back and Blackadder
and and shows like that that could only
have come from the UK
Barry Humphries could only have come
from Australia
what Barry Humphries would say is taking
the piss out of ourselves
and he did it so well and for such a
long period of time so it was a big loss
for the Australian Arts community and of
course he was equally as big here in the
United Kingdom and it says something
about our common history that that we
share and that engagement and
interaction I don't know that Barry
Humphries was very big in the United
States or in Asia or in in Continental
Europe but in the United Kingdom he was
big and in Australia he was of course
Larger than Life and there was a great
deal of mourning of him his comedy
rather light actually Monty Python
Blackadder all those kind of shows which
I love too almost certainly wouldn't
survive the modern curse of Council
culture because of the inappropriateness
Apparently Barry Humphries was canceled
by the Melbourne International comedy
show they took his name off the top
award for him being allegedly
transphobic what did you feel about that
was but I I didn't know I wasn't even
aware of that I must say until recent
recent times and and I think people uh
legitimately can put forward their
concerns about someone's comments that
were made then but at the same time
I think that we've got to be able to to
laugh at ourselves uh I think that a lot
of humor you're quite right that a lot
of humor that used to be on I mean
Faulty Towers I'm not sure how that
would go never never make it I'm not
sure
this whole idea of game I think there
were only there were only yeah I think
there were 12 episodes of Faulty Towers
and uh they were fantastic though good
fun and they weren't um
yeah it might be today you look at it
and you go you know well you know uh
maybe you you might do it differently
but a bit like um rewriting some books
um it is what it is at the time and it's
it's the uh it that's the context and
and I think that the idea of cancel
culture is in my view uh a sad
development because you you are often
can get as well uh pylons in social
media and you see it happen so often and
things quite often too taken out of
context I mean I I try not to look at
too much social media but I know that
sometimes people will say something to
me about an answer that in an interview
like this without people having seen the
question or what what's said before or
or afterwards and and make it look like
something that it isn't but I think that
we need uh far more should the Melbourne
far more tolerant should the Melbourne
International comedy uh
institution I guess they would call
themselves but should they have canceled
someone like Barry and doesn't do it
actually was that the worst kind of
council gotcha because that now since he
died they've now said we want to pay
homage to honor it seems to be stinking
hypocrisy yeah well I know kind of go
into the past because I wasn't a part of
yeah I wasn't ever aware that that
occurred but I'll say they said it's
good that a tribute is now being made to
Barry Humphries and there will be a
state funeral for Barry Humphries as
well uh co-hosted by uh the New South
Wales and the Victorian government and
the Australian government my government
will be a part of that as well so you
won't become tribute no we'll we'll be
paying tribute to him at a state funeral
he's someone who has given a gave an
enormous amount of pleasure uh to
generations of Australians and I know
that a range of people who are friends
of mine I knew him very well I didn't I
met him on one occasion briefly but I
didn't know him but I know how warmly he
was regarded by people in Australia and
in the UK they should have got him into
hot water
was this issue of gender identity he was
defending JK Rowling the New Zealand
prime minister knew his new prime
minister Chris Hipkins
um was asked to define a woman and he
said well people identify for themselves
he couldn't answer and it was
excruciating to watch to be honest with
you and this has been a sort of hot
potato question from world leaders
some of them seem incapable including
kirst
um
what is a woman prime minister an adult
female how difficult was that to answer
not too hard I was asked I was asked
during the campaign actually but I think
that
um you know we we need to I think I
respect
people for whoever they are
and it's up to people to uh you know to
be respected and and I know that there
is uh some controversy can come at times
like that and I'm not a fan of uh some
of uh the campaigners recently a very
controversial visit in Australia that
was designed to uh stir up issues and
people who are you know young people
coming to terms with their identity and
who they are I I think that they need to
be respected as well what would you do
for example with this issue of
transgender athletes in women's sport
which many world or sporting authorities
are now beginning to move to exclude
them because they say it's simply not
fair well that's an example in that the
sporting organizations are dealing with
that issue
my view is the sporting organization
should deal with that issue does it seem
fair to you the people who were born
biologically male with all the physical
Advantage should be able to compete
against people born with female biology
well in Australia the sporting codes are
able to deal with that uh and and and
they have and they have effectively and
they've done so in a way in which during
the last campaign there was one of the
candidates uh chosen who
tried to make that front and center that
issue I've got to say as I've gone
around and you know my son played Junior
sport
for both footballers and soccer and
Australian Rules Football and cricket
and everything none of these issues ever
came up and I don't think they're front
and center that's because he wasn't
happening then well I I well you didn't
get biological males competing against
biological women I mean that's that's
the problem with it to me to me I can
support transgender rights to fairness
and equality but right to the point
where they infringe on women's rights I
mean they've got to also have fairness
and equality and that's why sporting
codes uh should be dealing you're the
Prime Minister of Australia you must
have a view that's why sporting that's
my view are you ducking it no I'm not no
I'm not I'm saying that what it
shouldn't be done is I've done
to try to politicize an issue that
should be made on its merits based upon
the proper assessment of whether it's
fair or not but done in a way as well
that doesn't seek to essentially Target
a very vulnerable group and that's my
concern well I don't think they should
be demonizing anyway and that's my
concern as well I get that but I think
there's also there are serious issues
which have to be addressed of course
they are but it should be done without
the targeting of a vulnerable group of
people and that's my view that people
should be respected the sporting codes
are dealing with it and what occurred
when this debate happened in Australia
is the sporting codes said themselves
we're dealing with this we don't need
this to be politicized and we don't need
politicians buying into it
you're going to see Rishi sunak the
British prime minister I will while
you're here um are you going to mention
that you've just been uh in a poll named
the third most popular Global leader
while he languishes at number 10 and
that you also made time magazines 100
most influential people and uh in fact
the Prime Minister of Australia and in
fact the prime minister of Canada Justin
Trudeau said that you were effectively a
progressive champion
around the world I mean it's been a good
good couple of months for your prime
minister well well uh prime minister
Trudeau was very generous uh in his
comments I wasn't aware that I had been
named or that he was writing the
citation until it was uh pointed out to
me by the media I did send him a a
little message saying thank you for his
generous comments and I am looking
forward to seeing him again on the
weekend he of course will be here at the
coronation as the leader of another
Commonwealth country as for the first
that's the first I've heard of it but I
I won't be writing that with Rishi
sooner uh this is my third meeting uh
with him and we'll be talking about the
free trade agreement that can make an
enormous difference for Australia and
for the UK about how we can have mutual
benefit from increased economic
engagement and of course we'll also be
talking about our orcus Arrangements uh
further strengthening the cooperation
when it comes to our defense
one of your predecessors Paul Keating
wasn't exactly complementary about the
orcas Arrangement he described your 368
billion dollar deal for the nuclear
submarines as the worst deal in history
said you could have had 40 to 50
conventional Subs instead he also
attacked you for working with the UK
that offered a great problem of brexit
after that full Johnson Morris destroyed
their place in Europe they're going to
put together Global Britain so we're
looking around for suckers
are you a sucker
the orcas arrangement to me uh should
surprise no one
Australia if you look at our our history
we have
65 000 of proud history the oldest
continuous culture on Earth is
Aboriginal Torres Strait Islander
peoples but then we have
the relationship with Britain
and that's a relationship that goes back
to 1788 to the First Fleet and ever
since then we have stood side by side as
great democratic nations our Parliament
takes the Westminster system as the
basis of our our democracy and we have
common interests of course since the
second world war in particular under
Labor's prime minister John Curtin we
turn to the United States ever since
then the United States has been our most
critical Alliance partner so getting
greater cooperation between Australia
the United Kingdom and the United States
not just in Australia being able to
build our own
nuclear-powered submarines
is to my mind a very sensible thing to
do in today's uncertain world and I I
know former prime minister Keating made
some colorful comments I have every
respect for Paul but on this I just
disagree with him was brexit a good idea
that was a metaphor the United Kingdom
so was it a good idea well as the
Australian prime minister I don't see it
as my place
to put forward matters which are
strictly a matter for the people in the
government of the United Kingdom one of
the big reasons for orcas of course is
the ongoing threat of China potentially
invading Taiwan
Paul Keating said this I dare the prime
minister to explicitly suggest or leave
open the question that Australia might
go to war over Taiwan at the urgings of
the United States or anyone else so I
dare you to answer that question prime
minister well I want a region that is
peaceful that is secure that is stable
and that is prosperous and that's what
we're working towards but one of the
ways that we're also engaging in the
region is by lifting up our national
security we don't apologize for that we
have the orcas Arrangements we've just
had our defense strategic review as well
to look at what are the capabilities
that Australia needs and where do we
need them but do you think China May
obey Taiwan as many do well I don't
think it is
constructive to speculate on matters uh
like that we support the status quo when
it comes to Taiwan would you would you
support Taiwan if they were invaded we
are
Taiwan is not is not assisted by people
speculating on hypotheticals we support
well President Biden has we he's already
said that America would support them we
support the status quo being maintained
we support stability in the region and
we're investing in our capability but
we're investing in something else as
well we're investing in our
relationships whether it's orcas whether
it's asean whether it's our Pacific
friends through the Pacific
relationships that we have rebuilding
them but also we're engaging in the
region my government hasn't engaged in
uh rhetoric that is inflammatory what
we've said with regard to China is that
we will we will cooperate where we can
we'll disagree where we must and will
engage in our national interest but you
wouldn't just sit it back would you so I
couldn't sit back if Taiwan was invaded
you wouldn't think back as Australia's
prime minister well I don't I don't see
it as constructive uh to uh to speculate
on on hypotheticals what's important and
and the role of peace and security and
stability in the region is Advanced by
having a very clear position which is
support for the status quo of no
unilateral action uh by uh either side
in uh in in those issues and our
position on China has been to engage
constructively but to continue to put
forward that the impediments to trade
should be removed to say very directly
to president XI that Australians such as
Cheng Li need to be given proper Justice
and that they're not receiving that at
the moment and to raise those dishes to
raise human rights issues so we don't
shy away from that but we do so in a way
that's constructive and respectful and
that's how
you advance uh diplomacy that's how you
advance positive outcomes okay President
Biden said he's running again for for
office in 2024 he would be 82.
and he'd be 86 at the end of the second
term is he too old
that's a matter for the United States
but I don't believe that do you want to
be prime minister 86 anyway we'll see
how I go we'll see how I go that will
have sent a shiver down your opponent's
bones but can I say this about President
Biden I think he is doing an
extraordinary job uh I regard him as a
friend of mine I regard him as an
important uh leader of our most
important Ally I'll be welcoming
President Biden to Australia this month
for the quad leaders meeting and he
through his actions not just in
international relations where he is
strengthening the United States's
engagement in the Pacific and Indian
Ocean that's something that we welcome
you don't think he's too old when you're
dealing's with him you don't get a
feeling not at all not at all he's
totally on top of his brief he's someone
who's very conscious about uh Regional
Affairs in the indo-pacific region he's
someone who's engaged with our friends
with uh in Asiana I noticed uh today he
has the leader of the Philippines Marcus
uh they're hosting him in the white
house he's also got to engage with
potentially Donald Trump if Trump wins a
republican nomination president Trump is
actually in Britain at the moment are
you going to hook up with him are you
gonna no no I I engage with uh with
President Biden I look forward to
meeting him would you be happy to engage
with Trump if he was to win the White
House
our relationship with the United States
is a relationship between countries and
between peoples based upon our common
democratic values you'd have no problem
dealing with Donald Trump well well it's
not up to me to determine you wouldn't
have any trouble dealing with it no I'll
deal with whoever the president or or
the Prime Minister even if he's been
even if he's facing or the leader he's
been indicted on criminal charges okay
well that's a matter for you comfortable
with that that's a matter for the people
of the United States and I have no
intention of interfering in their uh
internal uh political processes I
expressed my concern would an Australian
prime minister do you think be able to
or what an Australian politician be able
to run to be prime minister if they were
indicted on
committing crimes uh well they would uh
I I think uh speculating on that uh I in
terms of either a labor or a liberal
candidate would I think have uh have
issues if that occurred but
um look I said uh very clearly I
expressed my concern about the events
that occurred in the capital on January
6 I don't shy from that I think
democracy is a precious
commodity a whole lot of the world it's
under threat
and that's why we need to support our
democracy
including supporting our Democratic
institutions Russell Crowe has part
owned the South Sydney rabbitohs the
rugby league club and you're a big fan
of them he's known you a long time
former board member right so he said
this about it with all the opaque
we've had to deal with the last
10 or 15 years we've got a guy you who
is at least going to tell us the truth
now he might not make the decisions that
you might that you want individually
every time but over time what Anthony
will do is improve the lives of the
people in this country and he also said
you never asked him for anything unlike
everybody else
um so he that's a that's a pretty good
review coming from Russell Crowe I
shouldn't think yourself as fools gladly
he thinks you're an honest person you
may make mistakes you might get things
wrong but essentially you're an honest
person and and I am and one of the
things that I've done as prime minister
is to say things the the way that I see
them so we've got a budget coming up
next week now we'll do
a number of measures to assist people
with the cost of living but we can't do
everything
on day one I haven't been in office for
a year yet and it follows almost a
decade of I think a government that was
characterized by inaction and delay and
denial that we're left with a trillion
dollars of debt so we've explained that
but we have fulfilled the commitments
that we made in the lead up to the
election to the best of our capacity but
of course all all governments and all
individuals including myself will make
mistakes from time to time are you
unafraid to admit when you're wrong I'll
give an example the small boats policy
which is a big issue here big issue in
Australia you know what you do with
people who wash up on your Shores you
were very opposed to it and you changed
your mind is that political expediency
the reality no it well it's looking at
the X the way that uh
they are and and and being upfront about
it you said this in 2015. I couldn't ask
someone else to do something I couldn't
see myself doing if people were in a
boat including families and children I
myself couldn't turn mud around
but now you can or changed uh the facts
um I didn't think that uh well you still
get people at the families and kids
turning up in boats I mean they're still
happening and and they have been turned
around are you comfortable at the time
yes because if you look at uh what
happened in practice with boat turnbacks
uh the view of what was occurring was
that the advice uh to us when we're in
government that if you tried to do that
then they'd Scuttle the boats and and it
would result in in tragedies
um so uh the the fact is that
the boat turnbacks policy was a part of
something that did make a difference I
support an orderly migration program I
have said that you can be strong on
borders without being weak on Humanity
so one of the things that my government
has done because we have ensured that
the boats contrary to what the
conservatives said before the election
campaign I must say some of the media as
well said oh well if if Labor's elected
the boats will start and it'll all start
back that hasn't happened we have kept
in place strong border security measures
but we also have an increasingly Humane
policy so for example that the people
who had arrived and were in limbo for
more than 10 years on temporary
protection businesses who no government
was going to send back to Iran or to
Afghanistan we have said that they
should be entitled to permanent security
to become permanent residents as well
we've abolished those temporary
protections when you're tough on Border
your anti-cancel culture
you know what a woman is
are you sure you're a progressive left
you're not a secret story in Disguise I
I I'm an absolutely uh consistent are
you an old-fashioned liberal a my kind
no I'm an old-fashioned who actually
realizes the woke left is pretty nutty I
must say that way Madness lies I'm a
Social Democrat who believes in markets
but believes that the state the power of
the state can make a positive difference
to people's lives that believes that the
philosophy I took to the election was
two two-part
now on held back and no one left behind
no one held back what does that mean
that people aspiring to a better life
for themselves and for their families is
a legitimate thing we need economic
growth we need to that's why I want to
make more things in Australia that's why
I want to lift Wages that's why I want
industry policy to kick in that's why I
want to challenge climate change and to
tackle it because we've seen King
Charles about that because he's
obviously been at the Forefront of that
for many years he's had a very strong
position in it he's been proven right
that child's about oh environment and
climate change he certainly has been and
one of the things about King Charles
over a long period of time is that the
stance that he has made on climate
change on the urban environment as well
on indigenous issues uh ones that I
think bring him great credit now I won't
talk about what I will talk to him about
that because that the protocol is that
that remains a private discussion and
we'll have a discussion this afternoon
but I I certainly think that he stance
on those issues has been very
significant but to go back to because I
don't want to miss the second Point
second point about what a labor prime
minister does is we don't leave people
behind so we're looking at that in terms
of the budget but we're doing that as
well with cheaper child care to allow
greater women's Workforce participation
we're dealing with that as well through
things like I marched in the Mardi Gras
to show my support for inclusiveness and
I'll continue to do that we are having a
referendum to give indigenous people
recognition in our nation's Constitution
I think you can do both things and
that's something that my government is
is focused on achieving we're only one
year in
to to our our first term been quite yeah
isn't it it's been a very busy year
obviously I want to end just just with
this I want to show you a picture
because I found this picture and if I
found it very poignant I'm sure you will
too you probably remember the picture
this is a picture on a boat and this is
1962.
and there are two people in that picture
this is the TSS Fair Sky it was a sipmar
lion boat
tell me who's in that picture well it's
my mum sitting there on the uh as I said
Marianne on the the far right she's next
to her brother uh George uh and uh
standing up in in white is uh a dashing
fellow who happens to be my father uh
Carlo who was a person on the ship that
my mother traveled to and that long
journey to England to England here where
she lived in London for a while and she
fell pregnant she did she had a
relationship with Carlo and uh during I
think not just on the ship but clearly
from piecing it together so you were
conceived in England when he
quite likely that's right so you're
actually you're one of us and when you
visit you're English right I'm still not
going for you in the ashes so don't try
that don't try that on are you except
you could have been conceived that's not
going to happen I think I think chances
are I was yeah I think I was here uh
when the ship used to birth at
Southampton and my mum uh
travel met him had a relationship with
him fell pregnant
he was in she when she told him he was
engaged to
someone he's uh the person who became uh
his wife back in Italy and so she went
back to Australia had me made the
courageous decision in 1963 to be a
single mother and to to raise me she was
very Catholic so it was a difficult
thing for the family and at that time
she was owes to it to have you adopted
she she was and that was what was very
common your life could have been so
different it would have been very
different and at the time it was to be
that I had been I would be adopted out
and that the story he would be told in
the local community and in the family
that she had got news of my father's
death and that had caused her to the
trauma to to lose her child but she
couldn't do that I was there was a
moment where a nun at the hospital knew
that she was the sort of person who
didn't she just really didn't want that
to happen she was under a bit of
pressure so she brought me into my mum
and my mom was never going to let me go
what a moment it it when I sliding doors
oh absolutely of an incomparable
enormous consequence oh and she then
adopted his name Albanese but continued
to to pretend that he had died in an
accident that's right and I was talking
to you yeah I was told that until I was
old enough when she felt I could
understand
um you were 14 of them it's 14 15. uh
you know and how did you feel when you
found out he's potentially still alive
oh I at the time I mean I was a pretty
tough young kid we had a we had a
difficult upper hand my mum
I had rheumatoid arthritis and was
crippled up was an envelope pensioner we
lived in a council house
where she had lived her whole life my
grandparents had died by then so it was
just me and Mum we didn't have anything
economically but I had her unconditional
love and that was enough for me and so I
said I'm not interested uh you know
that's you're enough for me which is
what she needed to hear so while she was
alive I didn't search for him but she
died in
2002 my son had come along
in 2000 and there was a moment where I
was at her gravesite and my little boy
was very little said you know where's
your daddy
and I sort of realized that yeah
I needed to and he had a right to ex
here understand
what had happened and so I I had I guess
once she passed away I could then search
for
him without uh bringing any
sense that she wasn't all I needed and
so I found him in 2000 well it's an
amazing story because this is nearly 40
years later yeah 46 years later
incredible I was 46 when uh when we met
right by pure chance
friend of yours is now running the ship
company that have been renamed several
times it was now Carnival Cruises you
knew this woman and she helped the
search and they find your dad's old
employment private details in some dusty
rickety area in Genoa where the original
ship stuff had all been sent yeah and
from that you were able
by now you're you're a minister right
under their trials a minister in the
government
and you're able to track down your
darling you're in a meet or you're in
your office I think and it's a Thursday
and you get a call from this friend of
yours is running the the ship company
but she just says we found him it was it
was a remarkable moment and I was
chairing a a Ministry or council meeting
of all the state and territory ministers
an important meeting that night
and I told my stuff to go on without me
and I just took I took my breath away it
was an extraordinary moment
well that's all from Piers Morgan on
censored tonight what an extraordinary
end to an interview there can't be many
world leaders who've got a more
remarkable backstory than Anthony
Albanese the Prime Minister of Australia
that's all for us tonight wherever you
are Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
well coming up on first edition in an
hour's time she came to London with her
parents as migrants from Guyana she went
on to become the first black female
cabinet minister and the first ever
black principal of an Oxford College and
on Saturday she has a starring role at
the coronation of King Charles we have
an exclusive interview with the
wonderful baroness Valerie Amos and just
24 hours a campaign left until the local
elections on Thursday the most important
set of elections in years it could be
the last for the journal action at the
latest on what it all means for Rishi
sunak and Kia salmon all that announced
time up next a change in the scheduling
Arthur Edwards and life with the royal
family a documentary
[Music]
thank you for the real crown experience
tune in to talk TV all this week for a
right Royal point of view don't miss
Piers Morgan very smartly he's now
moving to save the monarchy Jeremy Kyle
it really is a Monumental moment whether
you're a monarchist or not Vanessa
Phelps we can't wait we're counting down
we've got the mud we've got the Bunting
and TV Queen Mrs o he is a humanitarian
and he's going to do a great job only on
top TV
[Music]
thank you
I've been photographing the same family
for 45 years
I followed their lives across four
generations
[Music]
do the same with our children